So you've got a pretty
sweet looking control,
but what about users who
can't see the shiny hotness?
Accessibility is a key
consideration when building apps
and particularly when
you're creating new views.
You can start by adding
a content description,
as you would for every
other view in your layout,
to ensure that they are all accessible.
But what about views
like our wind speed
and direction gauge
where the content isn't static?
Knowing you're looking
at a wind gauge
isn't very useful
if you don't know
what the speed and direction
it's displaying are.
Well, there are couple of options here.
For generic views which
don't control their own values,
this simplest alternative
is to set the content description
within your app at runtime.
An even more robust solution
is to send an accessibility event
from within your view.
Whenever the visual content
has been modified.
Then override the dispatch
populate accessibility event,
and then the current control's
visual value, the accessibility event.
Go ahead and add
accessibility handlers to your view,
and then click here when you're done.